How should you check whether or not a file
or directory exists in Python?
This is one of those
things that's confusing
mostly because Python
offers several different ways to do it.
So, which one should you use?
I've seen many beginners
follow a path like this:
First, they check to see if the path
exists using something like `os.path.exists(file)`.
Print something
in return if it doesn't.
And then proceed to open the file
and do something with the data if it does.
In most situations, although
this does have some problems,
let's be honest, it's
probably fine.
For small personal scripts and otherthings like that,
I probably wouldn't even worry about it.
But if your intention is to build
something just a little bit more robust,
then let's take a
look at some of the issues.
The first issue is that time passes
between when we check to see if the file exists.
And when we try to open it.
It's possible that another thread or some
external process deleted the file
between when we check whether
it exists and when we try to open it.
If that were to happen, this open
call would raise an exception,
specifically a `FileNotFoundError`,
which is something that you might like to catch.
So really, we need to basically
repeat our error handling code.
Okay, so we surround
it in a try-except.
But wait, if `open()` was going to
throw if the file didn't exist,
then why did we need to
check if it exists in the first place?
And that's my point - checking whether it
exists or not is basically redundant.
If you're going to open the file immediately
after checking whether it exists,
instead, just try to open it.
It either exists and opens
successfully, or you get an exception.
When you do it this way, the
operating system will prevent other processes
from deleting the file out from under
you as long as you have it open in Python.
Although it typically will not prevent the
same process from deleting it out from under itself,
it's still possible that other threads
or processes read or write to the file
in between when you
open it and when you read it.
So, there are still things you need to worry
about, just a few less of them.
Another advantage of
this approach is that there are other things
that can go wrong when you try to
open a file besides the file not being found.
For instance, you might get an `IsADirectoryError` if
you try to open a directory instead of a file.
You could use the `os.path` function
to check if something's a directory,
but once again, you'd end
up with a potential very subtle bug.
If whether it's a directory or not
changes in between when you ask the question
and when you actually
try to open the file.
So, if you're checking whether the
file exists because you want to open it, then don't.
Just try to open it and catch
whatever errors you get.
And if you want to be super modern,
you might even consider using `pathlib.Path(file).read_text()`
as a quick one-liner to get all the data out.
But sometimes you don't
want to actually open the file.
You really do just want to
know whether or not it exists.
You could be using the
existence of a file as a boolean.
Checking whether an old temp file exists or
checking if the user made a configuration directory.
In that case, the recommended way to
check whether or not a file or directory exists
depends on whether you really need strings
or whether you could do with `pathlib` path objects.
Many applications default to strings
because it seems like the easiest choice.
And in a lot of cases, it is.
If that's you, then `os.path.exists`
might be what you want.
Hopefully, unsurprisingly, it tells
you whether or not the file exists.
`exists` will return true for files and directories,
and it also follows symbolic links.
In particular, `exists` will return false for a
symbolic link that points to a file that doesn't exist.
So even if there is an actual file for the symbolic link
at this location, it would still return false.
It does sound a bit confusing, but this
is the behavior that you would usually want.
If you want to check that you got an actual file
and not a directory or some kind of device object,
then you want `isfile()` instead.
Once again, `isfile()` follows links.
And this is probably what you want,
even though it sounds a little confusing.
And you guessed it.
For directories, there's `isdir()`, and it
also follows symbolic links.
So that's all fine
and dandy, and it works.
But using strings to represent
paths can be kind of error-prone.
Instead, using a `pathlib.Path()` can
provide a more ergonomic and safer interface.
If you already have a string, you can convert
it to a path very easily like this: `pathlib.Path(file)`.
Or you can do it like this if you're constructing
from scratch.
`path` provides a wrapper
around a lot of the `os.path` functionality.
And they make it easy to
access through method calls.
For instance, `path.exists` will
use `os.path.exists`,
`path.is_file` will use `os.path.isfile`.
and similarly for `is_dir` and a number
of other `os.path` functions.
If you're already using strings all over the place,
of course, there's a bit of overhead to convert.
But once you do, pretty much every built-in
function that takes a string path also takes a `pathlib.Path`.
And importantly, `pathlib.Path`
takes care of a lot of idiosyncrasies
that might come up if you
were to switch operating systems.
Things like using forward slashes
on Linux but backslashes on Windows.
Oh, and `pathlib` actually follows PEP 8.